this is our moment get out there and
tell the world that women deserve the
right to votes okay but you could vote
bathing costume carriage wash it is just
indecent women choose medicine but for
women I'm running for president you just
have to believe that you have them
already
[Applause]
it's a bumpy or she's kind of bump she's
gonna bump think enough the period
[Applause]
[Music]
look as though you could use a hand
blanch
it's very difficult to shovel coal while
caring for a baby rather than using the
better baby the girl it's making look as
much like a corpse as possible without
actually killing you
[Music]
[Applause]
the interest no are you a regular
or a nasty excuse me my name is
Lilia see well on the bright side we'll
never have to vote or get a job so yeah
right we're opening our own envelopes
now what are we coal miners